hat sich die politik verrannt erst
kategorisch gegen die impfpflicht nach
der bundestagswahl plötzlich dafür doch
dem kanzler und seinem
gesundheitsminister fehlt die mehrheit
das projekt impfen ab 18 in der
sackgasse
mitinitiator janosch dahmen kämpft
dennoch weiter wenn auch auf verlorenem
posten
ich glaube politik muss sich jetzt darum
kümmern das finde ich einen weiteren
pandemie herbst und winter erleben in
dem dann erneut licher einschränkungen
erforderlich werden und wenn wir das
ernst nehmen dann ist die impfpflicht
für alle erwachsenen der konsequente und
richtige schritte um hier vorsorge zu
treffen
impfpflicht befürworter auf der suche
nach einem kompromiss darüber reden vor
kamera will in der spd niemand auch
nicht der generalsekretär der vor
wenigen tagen erst per zeitungsinterview
dem kanzler von der fahne gehen ich
unterstütze den antrag für eine
verpflichtende impfberatung und die
anschließende möglichkeit einer
impfpflicht ab 50 jahren doch selbst das
wäre ohne stimmen aus der union
rechnerisch nicht möglich als
mehrheitsbeschaffer für die scholz
regierung steht sie nicht zur verfügung
timo sorge gesundheitspolitischer
sprecher pocht auf den eigenen entwurf
aufgabe wäre gewesen dass
gesundheitsminister sind auch des
kanzlers in der eigenen ampelkoalition
erstmal eine mehrheit für eine
impfpflicht ab 18 hinzubekommen das ist
schon gescheitert und danach zu sagen er
quasi als privatleute wir sind für eine
impfpflicht ab 18 kein regierungsentwurf
unterbreiten und jetzt auch dem
kompromiss den die unterbreitet haben
dich zustimmen wollen es ist schlechter
politischer stil
der gesundheitsminister bleibt dabei
ohne impfpflicht kein ende der pandemie
hauptgrund die impflücken unter den über
60 jährigen tatsächlich ist der
unterschied minimal etwa 90 prozent über
60 sind in deutschland geimpft in
griechenland trotzdem pflicht ab 60
sogar etwas weniger in italien mit
impfpflicht ab 50 leicht mehr in
frankreich ohnehin pflicht liegt die
quote etwas höher als in deutschland
linda teuteberg ist gegen eine
impfpflicht ihrer ansicht nach nicht
verhältnismäßig ist rohe trotz hoher in
sidenten keine überlastung des
gesundheitswesens es geht bei der frage
einer allgemeinen corona impfpflicht
nicht um ein kompromiss sondern darum
was in der sache richtig ist und zwar
verfassungsrechtlich politisch und
praktisch wir sollten auch übrigens in
europa nicht zum geisterfahrer werden
die allermeisten europäischen
demokratien kommen ohne eine allgemeine
impfpflicht aus und werben bei den
menschen für eine freiwillige impfung
scheidung und dabei sollten auch hier
bleiben kroner lässt sich nicht wie
pocken oder masern ausrotten alle
impfstoffe bieten lediglich eigenschutz
aber wie die fdp kürzlich vom
gesundheitsministerium erfuhr kann die
wirksamkeit des impfschutzes vor
schwerer erkrankung und übertragbarkeit
ein jahr nach einmaliger
auffrischimpfung aktuell noch nicht
eingeschätzt werden
impfpflicht auf verdacht eine medizin
ethische entscheidung der volksvertreter
kein fraktionszwang keine mehrheit in
der ampel und keine gesichtswahrende
lösung in sicht